[Musique]
si c'est bien le plus grand empire de
tous les temps il ne s'est pas bâtie en
un jour
de la grande
à la décadence
[Musique]
qu'ils rentrent
à la concurrence
rob
[Musique]
au bonjour je suis joe mantegna un
ancien philosophe a dit un jour tous les
chemins mènent à rome à l'époque il
n'avait pas tort il y a deux mille ans
toutes les autoroutes de l'époque
conduisait effectivement à l' empire le
plus puissant du monde
son histoire débute dans le tumulte de
la fondation de rome par remus et
romulus
elle se poursuit avec l'essor de jules
césar d'antoine et de cléopâtre de
spartacus et d'autres personnages plus
vrais que nature
tous issus d'une civilisation fait de
splendeur d'actes de bravoure mais aussi
de violence pure précis donc la
république de rome
[Musique]
ce sont les hommes et des femmes les
plus doués de leur époque ils sont
puissants
passionné et généralement inflexible
dans leur choix pendant plus de mille
ans il domine l'occident concurrents
leurs ennemis édifiant des villes
somptueuse et cultivons une vie à la
fois grandiose et décadente l' empire
romain aura longtemps captivé
l'imagination du monde moderne
[Musique]
hollywood elle même s'est attachée à
recréer les palets payen de robes ces
grandes fêtes publiques ses conquêtes
mêlant ruse et cruauté et surtout son
insatiable soif de vivre
souviens toi souviens toi tu ne veux pas
que tu n'oublies t'oublier c'est bien la
dernière chose qui pourrait m'arriver
[Musique]
on ne retrouvera jamais un empire aussi
vaste que le véritable empire rhône à
l'ancienne civilisation s'étend en effet
sur trois continents de la
grande-bretagne à l'afrique du nord et à
travers l'europe jusqu'en asie en
passant par le moyen-orient
si l'on doit cet empire les bases
durables une architecture ainsi que d'un
système juridique et militaires c'est le
peuple romain lui même issu
d'innombrables pays et cultures qui
incarne véritablement sa puissance sa
gloire et sa prospérité
[Musique]
le début de cette civilisation perdue se
perd dans les mythes et légendes
la plupart des romains situent leurs
origines aux rives du tibre dans une
région formant l'italie actuelle
[Musique]
au viiie siècle avant jésus-christ et
réa sylvia fille du légendaire roi
numitor donne naissance à deux jumeaux
remus et romulus
mais le frère de nuit tort craint que
ses petits fils ne détrône un jour leur
grand père dans un accès de folie
il jette le jumeau dans les eaux
glaciales qui
la légende veut qu une louve repêche les
deux frères et les élèves en les almées
pan de son lait
en 753 avant jésus-christ remus et
romulus sont adultes
il pose les fondations d'une nouvelle
ville qu'il baptise rome mais leurs
liens fraternels ne dure pas au cours
d'une dispute familiale mineurs romulus
tu remus et demeure le seul gouverneur
en place ses partisans s'établissent sur
l'une des sept collines qui forment la
ville nous sommes ici au bord de cette
colline du palatin est derrière nous se
trouve le capitole une autre des sept
collines qui entourent homme derrière
encore coule le fleuve la rome antique
s'étant précisément entre le tibre qui
sert de flux aux échanges commerciaux
entre le nord et le sud et les collines
alentours qui constitue un rempart
naturel un sommet dès qu'elles viennent
peu à peu s'établir différentes
communautés
[Musique]
sous l'antiquité l'italie est une région
de grande diversité culturelle
de nombreuses tribus comme les grecs les
sabbats et les latins commencent à se
mélanger pour former une nouvelle race
les romains
les premiers romain s'assemblent en
petites communautés qui se développe
sous la forme d' état indépendant
la plupart de ces peuples primitifs
vivent dans des huttes recouvertes
d'herbe sous l'autorité de roy issus des
familles les plus riches
mais 50 ans après que romulus et fondé
la ville l'une de ces tribus en plein
essor conquérir les communautés
dispersées et les rassemble sous une
monarchie dominante
ce sont les étrusques
les étrusques sont un peuple raffinée
dans les poteries et les peintures sont
de subtiles oeuvres d'art
il croit en la vie éternelle après la
mort et baptisent des tombes au style
élaboré
mais c'est également un peuple brutale
qui impose la terreur sur ses
compatriotes romain
en ce1 sont neuf avant jésus-christ
après plus de deux siècles d'oppression
un groupe d'aristocrates romain parvient
à évincer la monarchie étrusque il crée
à sa place un gouvernement
la république romaine dans le
développement dépasse bientôt les
espoirs les plus optimistes
on est à l'aube d'une ère nouvelle
l'époque des rois tyran est révolu le
pouvoir ne repose plus entre les mains
d'une seule personne
deux consuls dirige ce gouvernement ceux
ci sont des magistrats qui rédigent des
lois et supervise les affaires
juridiques
chaque année un comité le sénateur
participants par ses décisions à la
politique du gouvernement
elie de nouveaux consuls
la république de rome se compose de deux
classes de citoyens les plébéiens la
population courante composés des
commerçants des artisans et des
agriculteurs et les patriciens où
l'élite dominante qui détient le pouvoir
politique
la plupart des décisions que prenaient
les romains étaient improvisés
il n'avait aucun cadre constitutionnel
aucun garant comme nous avons pu avoir
jefferson madison franklin il n'y avait
pas de document écrit le renversement du
dernier roi étrusque avait permis de
mettre en place une république mais
l'ironie de la chose c'est que les
consuls qui l'ont remplacé au modelé
leur pouvoir sur ceux du roi qu'il
venait de destituer la seule différence
est qu'ils étaient dorénavant deux aussi
les plébéiens ne tardaient t-il pas se
plaindre que ce nouveau système n'est
pas vraiment mieux que le précédent
s'ils ont le droit de vote l'accès à la
fonction politique reste pourtant
réservé aux patriciens
en 471 avant jésus-christ les plébéiens
élise au sein d'une tribune qu'ils ont
créé un collège de dix représentants de
leurs classes chargées de les défendre
contre tous types de pressions
politiques de la part des patriciens et
des consuls en 450 avant jésus-christ on
vote une série de lois appelé les douze
tables destinées à protéger les droits
de tous les citoyens
au fur et à mesure que les siècles
passent le droit s'inscrit en profession
de prestige
cicéron un homme issu d'une famille
modeste devient l'un des plus éminents
juristes et orateur de robe
ses parents n'étaient ni des nobles ni
des sénateurs cicéron figure parmi les
quelques grands autodidacte c'est
l'avocat que tout le monde s'arrache
dans une époque où tout le monde peut se
voir intenté un procès pour un oui ou
pour un non
il est l'homme qu'on va voir lorsqu'on a
besoin d'elle ce statut lui confère
énormément de prestige
à la manière de nos grands avocats
cicéron et en public
amabile défenseur un comédien déployant
sa verve à travers la salle d'audience
pour l'une des ses plaidoiries
il va même jusqu'à emprunter à la rue
des orphelins afin de les présenter
comme les enfant famélique une femme
dont il défend la cause contre son mari
il s'adresse ainsi aux jurys
aujourd'hui je ne vous parlerai que de
l'innocence de ma cliente et je
m'efforcerai d'oublier complètement que
le plaignant est avant tout un infâme
coureur de jupons qui bat sa femme et
qui se permet de voler d'innocence grand
mère
si ses ténors du barreau font preuve de
leur talent en gagnant les procès c'est
sur les champs de bataille que la
plupart des romains montrent leurs
aptitudes
[Musique]
entre le cinquième et le 2e siècle avant
jésus-christ l'influencent de roms
s'étant hors des frontières de l'italie
chacun des deux consuls s'est constitué
sa puissante armée composée de légion
d'hommes provenant de différentes
classes ses légions romaines deviennent
peu à peu la machine de guerre la plus
violente que le monde est encore jamais
que nous c'est leur principale
motivation consiste à piller les
richesses des territoires alentours
ces mercenaires ne savent pas qu'ils
sont déjà en train de remanier le monde
peu à peu les territoires qu'il
conquiert deviennent des provinces
europe
au fur et à mesure de son expansion
l' empire romain hamas les fortunes des
nouvelles provinces kills est annexée il
ne s'agit pas de conquérir de nouveaux
citoyens qu'on pourra ensuite imposé
pour les besoins de la communauté
mais bel et bien de saigner les
provinces de leurs trésors toutes ces
richesses extorqué sont ensuite
acheminés vers rome
au 2e siècle avant jésus-christ l'armée
romaine a déjà conquis la majeure partie
du bassin méditerranéen dont la grèce
une partie de l'afrique du nord de
l'espagne de l'asie et du moyen-orient
les consuls ont délégué aux gouverneurs
qui l'ont élu la gestion des provinces
aussi la plupart des habitants de ces
provinces obtiennent le droit de devenir
des citoyens romains à part entière
[Musique]
lorsque les rats envahissent et un
paillis il avait pour principe de faire
participer les habitants de ce pays aux
conquêtes suivante
par contre ce que les romains n'ont pas
fait et c'est ce qui les différencie
d'autres concurrents sous l'antiquité
c'est de taxer le peuple de la péninsule
italienne
à la place ils ont préféré exiger de ces
communautés un quota annuel de soldats
c'est à dire un enfant un fils qui
permettent à leurs troupes de faire
perdurer leur force
le sorte qu'ils puissent continuer à
remporter leur victoire et a ramené des
richesses pillées dont tout le peuple
romain bénéficiera en retour
on achemine vers rome capitale de
lempire la plupart du butin
il y à là notamment des statues de
marbre et des reliefs qui serviront à
décorer le forum le centre administratif
de la ville
en cent ans avant jésus-christ le forum
est déjà un lieu débordant d'activité
c'est là que les orateurs s'adresse au
public face au palais du sénat dans les
nombreux temple dédié au dieu païen
comme jupiter minerve ou apollon les
citoyens pris et se livrent à des
sacrifices
le forum devient le centre florissant et
monumental véritable symbole de la
richesse et de la puissance grandissante
de rome
[Musique]
si l'on avait pu traverser le forum à
l'époque on aurait certainement pas vu
ce qu'on voit souvent dans les films
cette espèce de décorum vierge d'un
blanc très pur on y aurait trouvé à la
place une profusion de couleurs
il faut aussi savoir que rome était une
ville verticale les romains on inventait
nos gratte-ciel évidemment les immeubles
n'avait que 4 5 niveaux
[Musique]
pour ériger ces villes puissante
l'expansionnisme romain a besoin de main
d'oeuvre
de nombreux habitants des territoires
conquis deviennent des citoyens romains
mais bien plus nombreux sont ceux vendus
aux enchères comme esclaves
si quelques milliers d'entre eux s'en
tire avec une instruction une situation
convenable en tant que philosophe
musicien danseur ou professeurs
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'autres
sont astreints à un travail manuel
exténuant
[Musique]
je me trouve ici face à l'entrée des
carrières de syracuse
elle figure parmi les plus grandes
carrières de pierres de l'antiquité ici
même des esclaves se sont éreintés à
extraire de leurs propres mains la
pierre des édifices
beaucoup sont morts dans ce travail
dangereux et harassant auquel personne
d'autre ne se serait risqué
et lorsqu'on considère l'antiquité toute
entière son architecture classique c'est
imposant monument son art et sa
littérature
il ne faut pas oublier qu'elle s'est
appuyée à l'origine sur l'exploitation
esclave
voilà par exemple le genre typique de
chapiteaux que l'on sculpte est à partir
de ces pierres cette magnifique capitale
tout en pierres massives n'aurait pas
existé si autant de gens ne s'étaient
pas et chine et aux travaux forcés
si nécessaire l'armée romaine a tôt fait
de ramener l'ordre parmi les esclaves
rebelles de toutes les révoltes de
l'époque la plus importante a lieu dans
la péninsule italienne
elle démarre sous l'impulsion de
spartacus un esclave contraint de risque
et en permanence sa vie comme gladiateur
dans l'arène refusant sa condition
spartacus s'enfuit et commence à
rassembler autour de lui des dizaines de
milliers d'esclaves
pendant deux ans ils parviennent à tenir
en respect l'armée romaine
pendant qu'ils pillent de leur côté la
campagne italienne
[Musique]
révolte des esclaves de spartacus a été
capitale pour la perception que les
romains avaient de leurs esclaves
elle a été la plus violente des
rébellions
il a bien fallu deux ou trois légions
entières de soldats pour en venir à bout
elle a tout à coup fait prendre
conscience aux romains que ces esclaves
qui entretenait leur maison qu'il
côtoyait quotidiennement dans la rue
étaient des gens capables s'ils le
voulaient de les assassiner
dans leur lettre le mouvement mené par
spartacus a été un traumatisme terrible
pour la république de rome l'idée qu'une
armée d'esclaves puisse faire plier
l'armée romaine était une chose
impensable à rome afin de sauver la face
et de traquer les rebelles
les consuls de rome envoient deux de
leurs plus prestigieux commandant
crassus un riche général expérimenté au
combat et pomper un guerrier surdoué
dont les conquêtes lui ont valu le
surnom de pomper le grand
une fois qu'on vous a appelé le grand
alors que vous n'avez que 25 ans
j'imagine que ça façonne votre
personnage pour le reste de votre vie
pompey était un homme qui n'avait aucune
patience pour s'intéresser à la
hiérarchie politique il ne venait pas
d'une famille noble des amis lui lisait
des livres pour lui expliquer le
fonctionnement du sénat en 72 avant
jésus-christ crassus et des deux pompes
et emmène donc quarante mille hommes
pour chasser spartacus et ses esclaves
rebelles en moins d'un an
on parvient à rattraper la plupart
d'entre eux et on les tue parts à cusset
6000 autres finissent prisonniers avant
d'être crucifiés sur autant de croix
s'étendant sur des kilomètres le long de
la voie à piennes la voie principale de
rome la crucifixion était une forme
assez courante d'exécution dans
l'antiquité l'agonie étaient très lentes
et les supplices il nourrit en fait de
suffocation parce qu'ils étaient
entravés dans leurs mouvements
respiratoires ont laissé ensuite leurs
cadavres se décomposent et à la vue de
tous
au bord de la route ça a servi
d'avertissement
la révolte de spartacus est la toute
dernière guerre d'esclaves de
l'antiquité
crassus et pompé deviennent à leur tour
consul de rome leur victoire leur
confère les pleins pouvoirs sur le sénat
les un autre homme s'apprête bientôt à
gouverner à lui seul l'empiré romain
tout entier
[Musique]
ans
1er siècle avant jésus-christ l' empire
romain insiste à l'ascension de l'un de
ses plus grands chefs aux on dira de lui
qu'à la guerre personne le surpasse et
qu'en amour personne n'arrive à sa
hauteur on aurait pu ajouter qu'au fil
des époques
aucun autre nom n'aura été autant
synonyme de pouvoir absolu
[Musique]
né en lançant avant jésus-christ d'une
famille de patricien gaius julius caesar
finira par rester connu comme le plus
grands dictateurs du monde méditerranéen
ses parents sont extrêmement dures en
matière de discipline allant même
jusqu'à le battre fréquemment dans
l'espoir de l'an durci
[Musique]
césar est un homme grand et musclé aux
nerfs d'acier est tout aussi narcissique
que déterminés à réussir
[Musique]
à 18 ans il s'engage dans l'armée et
grimpe rapidement les échelons pour
devenir commandant
il est alors bien décidés à laisser la
marque de son passage non seulement sur
rome mais dans le monde entier
[Musique]
jules césar agit uniquement par ambition
il est en quête insatiable de pouvoir il
veut surpasser alexandre legrand qui à
30 ans a déjà conquis la plupart du
monde connu il ya comme ça une histoire
célèbres ou césar et en espagne est
content qu'une statue d'alexandre le
grand
ils font soudain en larmes et s'exclame
pas 25 ans je n'ai encore rien conquis
je pense qu'il brûlait d'ambition pas
uniquement d'être l'homme le plus
puissant qui soit les il voulait aussi
marqué l'histoire comme le seul homme
ayant été capable de surpasser alexandre
le grand
jules césar demande à ses soldats de
faire preuve d'un dévouement sans borne
en échange il les paie grassement sa
première conquête militaire le mène en
espagne en 61 avant jésus-christ
sa tactique au combat est extrêmement
violente elle révèle notamment un homme
susceptible d'être dangereux pour le
sénat à rome
c'est d'ailleurs à contrecoeur que les
sénateurs républicains le récompense à
son tour en le nommant vice-consul de
rome mais le titre ne lui suffit pas il
veut contrôler davantage le sénat qui
voit de plus en plus en lui un chef
militaire uniquement assoiffé de pouvoir
en soixante avant jésus-christ césar
convainc les anciens vice consul de rome
crassus et pompey d'exercer le pouvoir
républicain a droit cette alliance
en vérité avec la richesse de crassus et
l' influence militaire de pompey lui
permet de vaincre toute opposition
sénatoriale
les trois hommes créé le premier
triumvirat de rome césar conclut le
marché en autorisant pompey a épousé sa
soeur julia
césar s'avère aussi perspicace dans
l'arène politique que sur les champs de
bataille
il s'érige en homme du peuple et prend
des bains de foule dans les taudis de la
banlieue de rome afin de se présenter
comme le défenseur des laissés pour
compte
il s'agit évidemment moins d'un acte
bienveillant que d'une manoeuvre
politique visant à déstabiliser les
sénateurs conservateurs lesquels
continue volontairement de l'ignorer
parce qu'ils voient en lui un homme
bassement égocentrique
[Musique]
je pense que les citoyens de rome on
joue un rôle primordial dans son
ambition politique avec l'armée ils
formaient l'un des piliers de sa
puissance césar voulait être en
permanence sur qu'il bénéficiait
toujours de l'appui du peuple
il a déployé des efforts considérables
le plus souvent en manipulant la force
physique que représente une foule pour
s'assurer que la ville de rome continuer
de le soutenir
[Musique]
les trois dirigeants se divisent lempire
équitablement après leur mandat d'un an
crassus et pompey quittent leurs
fonctions ces arts en profite pour
acheter les nouveaux vice-consul de rome
afin qu'il le dote d'une arme est
suffisamment puissante pour conquérir
l'immense gaulle la future france
[Musique]
pendant neuf ans de 58 à 50 avant
jésus-christ césar narguant l'opposition
même plusieurs campagnes à travers la
gaule des expéditions cours desquelles
ils plient avec ses légions les
richesses du pays
[Musique]
le bilan en pertes humaines a été énorme
césar est responsable de la mort de plus
d'un million de personnes
on savait que les romains n'était pas
tendre avec l'ennemi mais la césar avait
dépassé toutes les limites ne faut pas
non plus oublier que c'est l'un des plus
grands criminels ayant existé
[Musique]
cette conquête de la gaule est l'un des
moments clés de l'histoire de rome césar
dispose dorénavant de l'armée et des
richesses susceptibles de l'aider à
vaincre n'importe lequel de ses
opposants y compris ses anciens acolytes
crassus et pompey qui en vit son succès
crassus fini par mourir à la bataille de
karaj contre les parts
sa tête servira même de masques au roi
des parthes au cours d'une pièce
dramatique grecque
à son retour à rome en 49 avant
jésus-christ césar trouve de nouveau
vice consul qui lui sont hostiles même
pompey a fini par se distancier et s'est
engagé au sénat aux côtés de ses
opposants crise et déclencher en 49 au
moment où césar a voulu rentrer à rome
pour reprendre le pouvoir
ses opposants refusaient il a déclaré
que ce refus constitué une négation de
ses droits et il a envahi l'italie césar
déclare la guerre civile à rome
il mène ses légions au bord du rubicon
le fleuve séparant la gaule de l'italie
là il s'adresse à ses troupes
acceptons ceci comme un signe des dieux
et suivons le chemin qu'il nous montre
vengeance contre l'ennemi qui nous ont
trahis
alea jacta est le sort en est jeté
[Musique]
en 49 avant jésus-christ césar traverse
donc le rubicon et prend le contrôle de
l'italien
pompey a déjà fui rome et mobiliser ses
hommes à pharsale en grèce les césars
traque son ancien partenaire et mène
contre lui une attaque décisive
[Musique]
les hommes de pompey dont beaucoup sont
intimidés par les troupes aguerries de
césar se mettent à déserter en masse
après un affrontement brutal
la victoire revient à césar
[Musique]
pompey a survécu aux balles sans il fut
aussitôt vers l'egypte avec césar à ses
trousses à son arrivée au port
d'alexandrie
ce dernier est accueilli par le roi des
égyptiens ce tome et les 13 qui n'a que
10 ans le jeune roi temps à césar en
signe de bienvenue la tête de pont b
c'est un geste de respect de la part des
citoyens égyptiens envers celui qu'il
considère comme le héros d'europe
rue du pot ce régime était un pays
extrêmement riche et intéressant à
conquérir mais l'anarchie politique qui
régnait pendant très longtemps les
romains l'ont laissée comme il était
parce qu'il n'avait confiance en aucun
aristocrate romain capable de s'y rendre
afin de s'en occuper correctement le
pays était trop riche et c'était trop
dangereux
à son arrivée ceara mesurer la situation
et a décidé qu'ils allaient stabiliser
le pays
l'egypte a besoin de l'appui militaire
de rome
mais un autre type d'alliance intéresse
césar
bientôt c'est avec la soeur du roi
ptolémée qu'ils s'associent son nom
n'est autre que cléopâtre
[Musique]
en 51 avant jésus-christ jules césar se
trouve pris sous le feu d'une querelle
familiale le roi égyptien ptolémée 12 a
légué le trône à son fils de 10 ans ce
taux les maîtresses ainsi qu'à sa fille
de 18 ans cléopâtre des deux co
souverain cléopâtre se révèle être la
plus douée c'est une jeune femme pleine
d'esprit et très cultivé
elle se sent parfaitement à son aise en
compagnie d'hommes puissants mais un
complot couve entre les murs du palais
alors qu'ils tentent de s'emparer de la
totalité du pouvoir
tollé mais fait chasser sa soeur de la
ville lorsque cléopâtre apprend que
césar se trouve à alexandrie elle veut
absolument le rencontrer
la ville est toujours entre les mains
des partisans de son frère aussi s'est
enveloppé d'un tapis oriental que la
reine entre clandestinement à alexandrie
[Musique]
le quinquagénaire est aussitôt séduit
par cette jeune reine de 18 ans
malicieuse et intelligente qui lui
raconte ses déboires
tous deux décident de s'unir il écrase
d'abord ptolémée et ses hommes une
ardente histoire d'amour commence entre
eux des semaines durant
ils se prélassent à bord d'un bateau
descendant le nil et observant les
couchers de soleil et eau pas très
bientôt enceinte de césar
ce sera un garçon
mais césar doit quitter sa maîtresse le
devoir l'appelle au commandement d'une
autre guerre
cette fois en asie mineure
en 47 avant jésus-christ ses légions
s'en prennent aux pharmaciens à la
bataille 2 et là c'est là qu'il prononce
sa célèbre phrase veni vidi vici
je suis venu j'ai vu j'ai vaincu
en 46 avant jésus-christ jules césar en
triomphant à rome cléopâtre et leur fils
césarion l'accompagnent
le peuple romain le nomme dictateur de
rome un titre pour lequel les citoyens
ne peuvent voter qu'en période de guerre
civile ou de crise politique
mais si l'on se confond en honneur pour
césar c'est avec méfiance que l'on
considère sa nouvelle maîtresse
cléopâtre faisait figure de menace pour
la société romaine son personnage allait
à l'encontre de tout ce que représentait
la décence féminine romaine
on la connaissait pour sa grande liberté
ces pratiques sexuelles
c'était comme si tout à coup le portrait
de la matrone romaine risquait d'être
remis en cause par cette sirène
cléopâtre était une mauvaise nouvelle
ce n'est pas la première fois que ces
arbres en maîtresse bien qu'ils soient
mariés alors à sa troisième épouse
calpurnia il a tout le loisir de la
trompait
l'adultère est en effet un droit pour
les hommes à condition que ce soit avec
une femme célibataire césar d'ailleurs
ne s'en prive pas car à part avoir été
un grand homme politique un grand
militaire et un grand administrateur
avait aussi l'air d'être un sacré
coureur il s'était fait une telle
réputation avec ses aventures qu'à la
fin on a même proposé qu'il est le
privilège de profiter de relations
sexuelles avec n'importe quelle femme et
avec autant de femmes qu'ils le
voudraient et même si c'est juste une
légende
cette histoire reflète bien en tout cas
sa réputation
je pense que ce devait être un homme
très séduisant il ya même eu des
chansons de soldats pendant ses
campagnes militaires lorsqu'ils
investissent est une nouvelle ville on
chantait en fermer vos femmes
ceara proche en même temps un homme qui
jouissait d'un tel pouvoir devait bien
séduire de nombreuses femmes
[Musique]
outre son goût prononcé pour les femmes
césar ressent en permanence le besoin de
faire étalage de sa puissance
faisant fi de l'assentiment du sénat ils
lancent plusieurs programmes de réforme
parmi lesquels l'annulation des dettes
des agriculteurs intelligent et
visionnaire il instaure le calendrier
julia de 360 5,25 jours c'est aussi en
son honneur que l'on s'inspire de son
premier nom julius pour baptiser le mois
de juillet
les classes populaires de rome
applaudissent ses efforts visant à
améliorer leurs conditions à leurs yeux
c'est un homme bon aussi en 45 avant
jésus-christ dans une démonstration de
gratitude sans précédent les citoyens de
rome le surnomme à 54 ans dictateur à
vie
dès lors il devient une menace plus
importante encore pour le vieil
establishment romain les sénateurs ont
peur qu'ils ne s'attribue trop de
pouvoir
un jour on l'a nommé dictateur et ce
jour là il a sans doute changer un tant
soit peu de personnalité lorsqu'un homme
prend autant d'ampleur et jouit d'autant
de gloire il est possible qu'ils
commencent à regarder en bas vers les
institutions comme le sénat
son utilisation abusive et désinvolte du
pouvoir va pourtant finir par le perdre
sous l'impulsion de cassius et de brutus
un proche ami le césar un groupe de
sénateurs conspirent son assassinat la
femme de césar californien l'a pourtant
averti après avoir fait un rêve
prémonitoire
mais césar ne tient pas compte aux ide
romaine de mars 44 avant jésus-christ
ces arbres se promène à l'intérieur du
palais du sénat
il ne se doute pas de l'imminence de sa
mort
quelques instants plus tard un gang de
sénateurs se jettent sur lui et le
poignarde à plusieurs reprises de leurs
dagues l'attaqué sauvage d'une extrême
violence
après avoir reçu 27 coup fatal il a le
dernier reflex de rabattre sa toge sur
son visage pour qu'on ne le voit pas
mourir
la nouvelle de son assassinat provoque
un véritable chaos dans les rues de rome
si les assassins sortent des salles du
sénat aux cris de liberté bon nombre de
ses sympathisants sont furieux antoine
alors député de césar lance un appel
émouvant au peuple romain afin que l'on
offre à leur chef des funérailles
publiques digne de lui
le discours d'antoine à une telle portée
que lorsque la foule a vu le corps
mutilé de césar
elle s'en est emparé afin de le brûler
par elle même les gens l'ont donc
descendu ici
à l'autre bout du forum elles ont brûlé
sur le champ
on a ensuite édifier un monument vous
pouvez encore en voir les restes ici
[Musique]
certains nostalgiques roma continue de
vénérer les restes que vous voyez ici à
chaque ides de mars
ce sont en particulier des royalistes
qui viennent déposer ici des fleurs à la
mémoire de césar le dictateur le docteur
après sa disparition césar devient une
icône romaine et ce malgré ses
détracteurs
on érige des temples à sa gloire dans
lesquelles ils demeurent l'archiprêtre
ou le pontife maximus certains l'élève
même rang de dieu si je dirais que césar
symbolise une chose positive et une
autre négative il représente le nouvel
état politique de l' empire romain le
concept d'un empire gouverné par un
empereur
il est vrai que jusqu'à justinien tous
les empereurs vont s'appeler césar et
d'un autre côté jules césar incarne un
frein pour tous ses successeurs
ils se souviennent que dans son parcours
pour devenir monarque
il s'est fait sauvagement assassinée
c'est une image qui va continuer de
hanter les empereurs au cours des six
siècles qui suivent
si césar a contribué à rebaptiser le
monde il a également laissé une
république romaine sens dessus dessous
au sénat les luttes intestines ont fini
par paralyser le gouvernement
il faut aussi se préoccuper de gérer une
population grandissante la république
doit donc se trouver d'urgence un
nouveau représentant
[Musique]
au milieu du chaos déclenchés par
l'assassinât de jules césar en 44 avant
jésus-christ robe toute entière vit dans
l'angoissé de lui trouver un successeur
si cléopâtre a porté le seul et unique
fils de césar scénario c'est le fidèle
député antoine qui se positionne comme
héritier légitime
mais même une fois mort césar continue
de dicter son choix politiques
on apprend dans ses volontés qui l'a
adopté à titre posthume son petit neveu
octave celui ci n'a beau avoir que 19
ans et être inconnu c'est pourtant lui
qui hérite de rome et de toutes la
succession de son oncle
[Musique]
et en effet un de baroque tarn a appris
son adoption qu'après le meurtre de
césar saint figurait dans son testament
lui a d'ailleurs fallu énormément de
courage pour venir à rome revendiquer
l'héritage mais c'est pourtant ce qu'il
a fait il a commencé à faire de la
politique politicienne et a essayé de se
mettre l'armée dans la poche
il a joué un double jeu d'un côté contre
antoine et de l'autre contre les
conservateurs octave a démarré sa
carrière en démagogues dont la seule
ambition était de prendre le contrôle
d'une armée octave plus connu sous le
nom d'octavien fait figure d'adolescents
gâtés c'est un jeune homme faible
physiquement et incompétent au regard
des responsabilités gouvernementales qui
l'attendent
ils se heurtent dès le début à
l'opposition d'antoine celui ci est
aussi un chef militaire effrontée qui a
prouvé son dévouement à césar au cours
de plusieurs batailles clés antoine
avait une réputation terrible de
débaucher il se livrait à des orgies à
des beuveries et coucher avec des hommes
et des femmes
le grand orateur et politiciens cicéron
ne s'est pas privé de l'attaqué
violemment sur tous les aspects de sa
vie privée comme publique en le traitant
par exemple d'abrutis par l'alcool ou de
loque humaine menée uniquement par le
sexe
il y a une anecdote qui relate un
incident au cours d'une réunion
politique antoine sied présenter un
matin alors qu'il était encore sous
l'effet des nombreux excès de sa nuit
passée ils n'avaient pas dessaoulé et il
s'est mis à vomir sur sa toge en pleine
assemblée
octavien tourne alors à son avantage le
comportement indiscipliné d'antoine
l'adolescent est ambitieux et rusé et
l'a compris qu'il lui faut d'abord
s'allier avec antoine s'il veut
s'emparer de la totalité des pouvoirs
sur lampy octavien à régler chaque
détail de son plan ils commencent par
donner à rome son second triumvirat en
partageant le pouvoir avec antoine et
lépide un ancien gouverneur de province
romaine
l'epide équipes d'ailleurs bientôt cette
coalition tripartite octavia et antoine
se partagent donc à deux la gestion de
lempire
octavien prend en charge les provinces
situées à l'ouest parmi lesquels
l'espagne l'italie et la gaule et de son
côté antoine régis les provinces s2
d'afrique du nord et d'asie
suivant les traces de césar antoine fini
par faire alliance avec la reine
d'egypte cléopâtre
première grande rencontre a eu lieu sur
ce qui représente aujourd'hui la côte
sud de la turquie
cléopâtre a grandi c'est une femme avec
bien plus d'expérience qu'elle n'en
avait au moment de sa relation avec
césar pour venir au devant d'antoine
elle remonte donc le fleuve dans un
grand navire décor et de tentures doré
et violette elle même est censé s'être
vêtues à la manière de la déesse venus
il ya autour d'elle des musiciens des
parfums se répandent dans l'air toute
une mise en scène en vérité
ces rameurs caresser l'eau avec des rats
mon argent qui savent et c'est dans
rythme au chant des flûtes plutarque
cléopâtre qui a cessé de pleurer la
disparition de vue mme césar ton
désespérément amoureuse dès sa rencontre
avec l'ambitieux antoine et cléopâtre a
tiré des leçons de sa liaison avec jules
césar par uniquement amoureuse mais
aussi sur la manière de manipuler les
puissants généraux romains elle a appris
de ribambelle d'exercice sexuelle comme
politiques qui vont lui permettre de
séduire antoine bien entendu ça marche
dans les deux sens
l'essentiel reste que césar antoine et
cléopâtre savez chacun exactement ce
qu'ils faisaient
s'il tombait amoureux et touchante
ensemble ils savaient pourquoi il
s'agissait en fait d'un accord tacite
entre des individus puissants qu'ils
savaient à quoi s'en tenir et la liaison
entre antoine et cléopâtre fait
évidemment partie des relations les plus
célèbres de toute l'histoire
mais le plus intéressant c'est
qu'antoine a ensuite quitté l'egypte
pendant quatre ans et n'a pas cherché à
revoir cléopâtre pendant ce temps là
apparemment elle ne lui a pas vraiment
manqué et pour cause c'est à cette
période qu'il a épousée octavia la soeur
d'octavien antoine espère que son
mariage avec octavia lui assurera la
loyauté d'octavien mais lui même fini
par abandonner sa femme et retourne à
alexandrie conclure un accord politique
avec les eaux pâtre
les deux amants projette d'évincer le
jeune octavia afin de gouverner tous
deux le monde occidental mais en réalité
leur collaboration offre à octavien
l'occasion qu'il attendait depuis
longtemps
octavien lance alors une impitoyable
campagne de propagande
il raconte au peuple romain que
cléopâtre a ensorcelé antoine que les
deux amants passent leur temps dans de
gigantesques banquet et orgies et
qu'antoine a l'intention de déposer la
moitié de l'empiré romain au pied de son
amante cette campagne de diffamation
fonctionne à merveille les citoyens
romains se rallie à sa décision de
déclarer la guerre à antoine et à
cléopâtre à la bataille d'actium en 31
avant jésus-christ les soldats
d'octavien vain que les navires
d'antoine et de théo pâtre sur la mer
méditerranée
[Musique]
parvenant à s'extraire sain et sauf de
conflits navale le couple se réfugie en
egypte
[Musique]
mais antoine et cléopâtre savent que les
hommes d'octavien sont à leurs trousses
la toute dernière décision d'antoine
consiste à se retirer dans ses
appartements
là il saisit son épée et se fera pas la
poitrine
c'est une mort lente et douloureuse
lorsque cléopâtre apprend qu'antoine a
mis fin à ses jours
elle décide de le rejoindre la reine
égyptienne enroulé alors à serpents
venimeux autour de son bras qui ne tarde
pas à la mort il ne s'aime on peut dire
qu antoine et cléopâtre ont tous deux
choisi de se suicider pour ne pas
entacher leur réputation
si au contraire il avait fait le
triomphe d'octavien son retour à rome
les choses auraient été à leur sens
beaucoup plus compliqué tous deux ont
choisi de sortir de la scène politique
de la manière à leurs yeux la plus
décentes et la plus noble
antoine et cléopâtre morts les hommes de
main d'octavien règle son compte au seul
fils de césar césarion
lui personne ne risque désormais de se
mettre en travers du chemin d'octavia la
république romaine a cessé d'exister
à sa place octavien participe à la mise
en place d'un nouveau gouvernement
lempire de rome le rêve d'octavia est
devenu réalité
il est à présent le premier empereur de
rome est le seul gouverneur de la nation
la plus puissante de toute l'antiquité
[Musique]
ça vient avec une ascension
spectaculaire vers le trône impérial
on le baptise alors auguste ans ce qui
veut dire mi dieu pour le peuple romain
auguste devient l'être humain le plus
proche de dieu son règne apparaît comme
l'une des périodes les plus brillantes
de toute l'histoire romaine une période
possibilités infinies être alors un
romain c'est voir toutes les portes
s'ouvriront
[Musique]